Heroin is a drug that is often abused for its powerful pain relieving effects,
both physical and psychological, as well as the euphoria. However, tolerance
develops to the effects of heroin, and that requires the user to take more of
the drug to produce those similar effects. In addition, once the heroin addict
is physically dependent When the drug starts to leave their system, they'll
experience withdrawal symptoms. Thus, the life of a heroin addict is a vicious
cycle, spent injecting the drug. Experiencing effects. And when that starts to
wear off, they're going to seek to find the drug again. Often times, this
resolves in criminal activity in an attempt to purchase the drug. Now, heroin
is not used here medically in the United States, but other powerful opiates
are. However, although some people do abuse the opioids, it's important to
stress the value of these pain-relieving agents. From a medicinal point of
view, these are essential for managing individuals who experience pain. Now,
the opiates produce their effects by interacting with our mu, delta, and kappa
receptors and they act similar to our endogenous endorphins and enkephalins.
People often die from overdosing on these drugs by respiratory depression. Now,
I'm going to send it back to Lauren and we're going to discuss the next drug,
cannabis.